si vous avez regardé la vidéo
précédente vous savez maintenant quoi
faire si vous vous trouvez face à une
personne inconsciente et qui respire
mais si vous tombez sur quelqu'un de
conscient et qui étouffe
vous faites quoi?
eh ben on va voir ça tout de suite
Doug Ross, Cecilia Reyes, Gregory House, Michaela Quinn, Derek Shepherd, Elliot Reid
Quel est leur secret pour être si sexy?
ils sauvent des vies
ça vous fait une bonne raison d'apprendre à sauver des vies
l'autre raison c'est qu'apprendre à sauver
des vies, ça peut sauver des vies!
*introduction*
imaginez un peu, vous sirotez un cocktail dans une soirée chic
quand soudain dans l'assistance un individu avale son cake aux olives de travers
on appelle ça faire une fausse route
son morceau de cake aux olives au lieu de prendre la direction de l'estomac en passant par l'oesophage
il s'est dirigé vers les poumons via la trachée
et il s'est coincé là
et le pauvre bougre se met à étouffer au milieu des convives
ce qui chie un peu l'ambiance on va pas se le cacher
mais procédons à une reconstitution de la scène
avec notre mannequin de secours
oh la la je suis actuellement en train de m'étouffer avec du cake aux olives
non, en réalité le pauvre bougre en question, s'il est en train de s'étouffer il peut pas parler
il ne peut pas non plus tousser, il ne peut pas non plus respirer
pour faire tout ça il faut de l'air et que là
pour le coup il y a du cake aux olives qui empêche l'air de passer
c'est le principe de l'étouffement
*Maxime s'étouffe*
sans ces cas-là il faut tenter de faire
sortir le morceau de cake aux olives
en pratiquant ce qu'on appelle la méthode
de heimlich du nom du médecin
américain qui l'a mise au point mais
avant tout il faut demander à quelqu'un
de prévenir le samu au 15 parce que vos
camarades là, il est en danger de mort
avant de commencer penchez le convive en avant, soutenez-le au niveau de la poitrine avec une main
et envoyez-lui 5 grandes claques entre les omoplates
avec le plat de l'autre main
si le cake aux olives est sorti, le convive se met à tousser
par contre s'il est toujours là où il devrait pas, il faut passer aux choses sérieuses.
placez-vous derrière votre camarade qui
est en train de s'étouffer
passez vos bras sous ses aisselles, mettez votre poing entre son nombril et son sternum
appuyez votre main à plat par-dessus, serrez bien fort et tirez d'un coup sec vers vous et vers le haut.
dans la vraie vie se seras moins gênant avec quelqu'un d'habillé, promis
l'idée c'est de faire pression sur les poumons  pour que l'air comprimé fasse jaillir le morceau de cake
comme un bouchon de champagne
vérifiez régulièrement si le morceau n'est pas ressorti ou si il n'est pas remonté dans la bouche
et tant qu'il est coincé
recommencez les mêmes manipulations
jusqu'à ce que les secours arrivent
5 grandes claques dans le dos, 5 compressions abdominales jusqu'à ce que ça sorte
Julien: attends t'es sûr que c'est pas sorti?
Maxime: ah non non non Julien j'étouffe horriblement
Julien: attends mais tu parle là
Maxime: me laisse pas tout seul Julien
si tu pouvais juste arrêter les claques dans le dos ça serait parfait
Quand le morceau de cake aux olives finit par sortir, asseyez la victime
restez avec elle, surveillez-la et rassurez-la en attendant l'arrivée des secours
d'ailleurs si personne ne les a encore appelés c'est le moment de le faire
pareil si vous avez un doute, appelez le 15, ils vous diront quoi faire
attention si ça fonctionne pas, le convive va finir par perdre connaissance
dans ce cas-là installez-le doucement au sol et commencez un massage cardiaque
si vous savez pas comment faire non plus, on verra ça dans une prochaine video
ah, dernière chose
la méthode de Heimlich, ça marche avec tous les corps étrangers
pas juste les cake aux olives
voilà des dtc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau geste qui sauve
abonnez-vous pour pas rater ça d'ici
là éviter les ennuis, prenez soins des autres
et de vous-même
et portez-vous bien